welcome to their technology Tuesday
today Mason a question from one of my
youtube viewers love you guys
Suzanne wrote in the say only suggestion
is show us how you make these notes is
it a simple cut and paste so Suzanne
there are four main ways that I add
content to my Evernote notes and I'm
going to show you each one so I mean my
ideas notebook and I thought I'd add a
new note so I'm gonna click on the add
new note and the first main way that I
actually add notes is just by typing
this is a simplest version and this is
the easiest and the one that I use most
often so say I'm working on a new
project that's gonna be about my book so
I'm gonna write book ideas as my title
and then I'll just write in a whole
bunch of things that I need to remember
notes I want to keep things to remind
myself up it could be you know interview
famous entrepreneurs
it could be connect with publisher it
could be yet graphic design whatever my
list of ideas and this is how I take
most of my notes when I'm in meetings
I'll always use that and just type notes
and again it syncs between your phone
your computer desktop and anywhere you
have Evernote installed so that's the
easiest one the next is copy and paste
yes you can copy and paste ideas notes
from other places so as an example if I
go to even your message here say I was
gonna put this in my Evernote I could
just highlight it copy it and then go
back to Evernote and paste it in either
the the picture or as text and then I
have that as a note as well the third
thing you can do is use an attachment so
if there's a PDF or picture that you
want to include in it then you can add
that in as well so I'll just add an
extra line so it's up here at the top if
you click on the arrows if you don't see
it immediately let's add it below
there's a little paperclip click on that
and then load up your your file manager
you can pick whatever you want say my
name i platform document in here it's a
PDF I could put that in there and it'll
load the entire PDF here for me to look
at as I want to and go page by page if I
wanted to add a picture in
I could do the same thing click on the
three arrows go back to the clip I could
put the picture and it'll load that
there so I've got just typing I've got
copy and paste and I got the including
the attachments the fourth one is using
their Web Clipper so if you use whatever
browser I'd like to use Chrome there's a
little Web Clipper at the top here that
you can install it's a free extension
that clips things Evernote so say
there's a web page an article that I
really like let's do something about
book publishing and okay so there's this
Wikipedia article maybe I really like
this has given me lots of great
information I want to share I can you
know say this is what I want to keep I
can highlight it then click on the clip
to Evernote button I can choose if I
want to clip just a selection the full
page the article a bookmark a screenshot
pick whatever I want I could pick my
folder so put it to the ideas folder say
I want to clip the whole article because
I it's super valuable and I need it for
next time I'm gonna click Save it's
gonna save it to my Evernote so it's
syncing
this is clipped to ideas great thank you
so much and if I go back to my Evernote
and then sync you'll see that it's
created a new note in that folder and
here's the full article that I can keep
reach the later use for future reference
whatever I need it for so in summary the
four ways to add notes to your Evernote
number one type it in number two copy
and paste
number three add an attachment number
four use the Web Clipper and believe
those you watching like the video you
can subscribe to the channel see more
just like it thank you so much for
watching I'll see you soon
don't forget to click here to subscribe
to my newsletter to get actionable
inspiring motivational believe advice
every single week to your inbox hi I'm
Jason Grif on see you got Rosalyn calm
and I want to say Evan Carmichael's
newsletter is consistent fun inspiring
and it's the only newsletter I
prioritize and look forward to period